bien fue una gran victoria para macrón
al presidente reconoció que mucho del
apoyo que recibió fue para frenar al
epen qué lectura podemos hacer de esto
muchas gracias en efecto se puede hacer
una lectura bastante pesimista para el
mandato que empieza a emanuel makoun
para los próximos cinco años en la
mayoría de los votos han sido votos de
rechazo hacia marín marín erpen y hay
poco apoyo popular para el nuevo
presidente para pues su segundo mandato
como presiente de la república de
francia
ahora todos los partidos se han volcado
a lo que denominan como la tercera
vuelta electoral es decir las
legislativas que podemos esperar de
estos comicios logrará macro no unir al
país como lo prometió
hay mucha incertidumbre frente a las
legislativas porque pues vimos tres
líderes que emergieron durante esa
elección presidencial - son a la
izquierda y makro al centro derecha
imagen no dependa la otra derecha pero
ninguno de esos tres líderes tienen
realmente un partido hegemónico en su en
su bando entonces van a tener que buscar
alianzas encontrar candidatos la mayoría
de los diputados del mandato precedente
eran eran nuevos eran debutaban con ese
tema de la de la representación nacional
y muchos no van a seguir no tenían este
apoyo popular en sus regiones entonces
se van a tener que reconfigurar esos
bloques encontrar candidatos entonces
bloque lo que lo que prima es la
incertidumbre acerca de la posibilidad
de unificar esos bloques y para makoun
de lograr una mayoría que le permita
llevar a cabo su política ahora echemos
un vistazo a los resultados en
territorios de ultramar por ejemplo a
diferencia de 2017 esta vez fue el epen
quien recibió un mayor apoyo en vez de
macrón de este cambio
ese cambio es una sorpresa porque pues
el partido
nacional el frente nacional es el
ancestro del partido actual de la bnp ha
sido un partido muchas veces condenado
por racismo y entonces en esos
territorios de ultramar donde hoy hay
una mayoría de habitantes de que son
afrodescendientes no se esperaba en
digamos esta victoria de lópez 30 macro
lo que sí se puede ver es un rechazo muy
fuerte en estas zonas periféricas hacia
la política de macrón que no les sirve a
las poblaciones más pobres y más
marginales del territorio francés